okay i'm uh not sure if you're familiar
with this app it's pretty popular it's
called cameo you've probably heard of it
it's an app that allows you to pay a
celebrity
to record and send a personalized video
to you
or your friends it's very popular a lot
of different celebrities are doing it
and they're making some quick cash well
recently check this out
uh carol baskin from the netflix
show tiger king she joined cameo
she made over a hundred thousand dollars
in her first week
yes that story is getting a lot of
attention carol baskin made a hundred
thousand dollars in a week
however carol has one rule on cameo
she is not willing to talk about her
dead husband
who many people think carol baskin
murdered by feeding him to a tiger
guess what that's the only thing people
want carol baskin to talk about
yeah and she won't say a word about it
but not to worry i found a celebrity on
cameo
who will only talk about carol baskin's
dead husband
yes take a look hey tiffany
andy richter here happy graduation hey
you know who's not graduating
carol baskin's dead husband
happy sixth birthday millie you know at
six years old a tiger is fully grown
and could have easily fully consumed
carol baskin's husband
leanne good luck in college from your
old high school coach mr
engelbrot although you called him mr e
do you know what else is a mystery what
happened to carol baskin's husband
hey there todd i am so sorry for your
loss
but you know the thing is everyone dies
at least you can find solace in knowing
that your great-grandmother wasn't
murdered
by a tiger-obsessed lunatic named carol
baskin
hey samuel happy bar mitzvah today
you are a man you know who's no longer a
man
carol baskin's husband because she
turned him into tiger feces
well mazel tov anyway god bless you andy
richter
we have a uh great show tonight don
cheadle
gonna be joining us we'll take a break
we'll be right back
huh would you say i wasn't done yet
i was going to deflate the half turn but
you got impatient
and called it nice
done